Optimizing the performance of your Android app is about how you manage your memory.
More often than not, problems here can arise from the use of groups
Which may not be economical when it comes to the source.
My name is Colt McCannless
To help you write better-performing apps,
The Android system provides a list of groups designed specifically for mobile phone development.
Consider the commonly used HashMap object.
It is quite useful from a language perspective, but it is also a major obstacle to memory.
As you see, the typical HashMap system works a bit like this.
You take a basic object and apply it hash,
Which gives you an index in a large matrix.
In the position of that index, you can place the value of the object,
Which means that the biggest problem you have to avoid in design are clashes,
Or alternatively, when multiple keys are split into the same place in that array.
Now, small matrices mean
It will end up with a lot of hash collisions.
I mean, when you plan 20,000 objects in 10 locations, by definition,
Will lead to little chaos.
As such, most HashMap will eventually allocate a large matrix
In order to reduce the likelihood of collisions,
Then go to add a little crazy logic in the event that these things happened,
Such as sequence algorithms and others.
So it is clear that this entire matrix contains a small number of objects
Not really ideal for the minimum hand of machine memory,
This is why the Android environment provides an alternative container category
Which are more efficient than memory, ArrayMap.
ArrayMap provides HashMap matching function, but avoids all overheads overhead
Using two small matrices instead of a large matrix.
The first array contains hashes for the given keys in their order of the workbook.
The second matrix stores the key and the value of objects that are inserted into the group,
Are intertwined according to a hierarchical matrix arrangement.
When you want to bring value, we will create a hash to get the key
Then we do a binary search of the hash matrix to find the index.
We can use this index immediately afterwards to find the location in the key value pair
In the interlocking matrix.
Now, if the key in the second array is not equal to the key
Which we delivered when we were looking for things,
Then we assumed that there was a collision.
To solve this problem, we'll follow the keys in both directions,
To try to find the right match.
These mean that the more objects in the container,
Time is also needed to access a single object.
Basically, you're balancing the smaller memory costs for the most expensive time of arrival.
Now, as long as these arrays are contiguous in memory,
There are some things you should remember about using them.
Mainly understand how delete and add to containers.
Deleting items can occur in two paths.
Either be lucky and need to do just pressure step,
This means moving the deleted items to the end
Then move all other values ​​forward.
Or you could end up in the slowest path
Which in fact requires changing the size and copying of the elements to remove the value in demand.
Inserting is in the flip side of this currency.
If the matrix is ​​compressed,
After that we can reuse those custom blocks,
Then move everything to keep our workbook arranged.
However, the slow path requires a full resize of the adjacent array
In order to create space, as well as copy and move everything.
In general, this means that the insertion and deletion of the ArrayMap
It will cost a little more in terms of performance.
But if you leave the number of objects in them small, such as hundreds of objects,
This is not really something to worry about.
Note that these arrays are small contiguous
Means that when the number of values ​​is very low
You will have a lot of savings compared to the standard HashMap.
For blank maps, there are no existing allocations to occupy the area.
For a small number of objects, it is the perfect choice for memory.
By the way, there is another wonderful feature for these containers
Is that you can repeat using indexing on them.
Compare this with the HashMap container, which requires you to use the refined form,
This, of course, is much slower and requires more memory to accomplish.
But obviously, it is not wise to use these improved containers in each case.
But there are some optimal situations to consider.
First, in cases where you have a few items,
Where they number in hundreds or so,
Of many accessions, or insertions and deletions that are rarely repeated
The cost of doing so is not really remarkable.
Secondly, in cases where we have maps containers such as map maps,
Sub-maps tend to have few elements
They will often be repeated several times.
If your use is not in any of these situations,
It may be better to stick to the HashMap class,
Which in fact highlight a very interesting point.
Performance improvement is an ongoing tradeoff
Between finding the right container for the correct usage pattern for the correct memory pattern.
As one of them said, there is no magic solution,
That's why you need to check out the rest of Android's performance patterns
For more information on these types of swaps.
Do not forget to join our community on Google+ as well
To hear other war stories from developers who have faced similar situations.
So stay calm and type your code, and always remember, performance is important.